puede que al inicio sí haya habido
cierta confusión entre la población por
la cantidad de candidatos pero en las
últimas semanas han habido seis
candidatos por los que la gente se ha
decantado sin embargo no hay ninguno que
logre arrastrar todo el voto creo que
tiene que ver con algo que los
especialistas llaman como una de
ideologización de la población es decir
que no votan necesariamente basados en
ideologías y también con que no hay
ningún tema que haya polarizado la
campaña y los planes de gobierno son más
o menos parecidos todos ofrecen
reactivación económica más empleo y
menos corrupción y es por eso que hasta
ahora la gente sigue pensando su voto
hay debates de la noche pasada y también
esta noche habrá un debate que la
población podrá ver para decidirse o
bien un 13% de la población podría
decidirse incluso en la urnas como
sucedió en la elección pasada de 2018
usted nos hablaba de que hay seis
candidatos por los que la gente se ha
decantado y los sondeos arrojan cuatro
favoritos cuéntenos por favor más de
ellos
así es el candidato que lidera las
encuestas es josé maría figueres él es
expresidente de la república el de 1994
1998 y bueno corre por el partido
liberación nacional de tendencia
socialdemócrata también está en segundo
lugar la candidata de otro partido
tradicional dine saborío ex
vicepresidenta de la república de la
unidad social cristiana y luego le sigue
el candidato fabricio alvarado de nueva
república es diputado periodista
salmista evangélico y que corrió en la
contienda pasada y que fue derrotado
finalmente por el actual presidente
carlos alvarado en una campaña que sí
fue polarizada por el tema del
matrimonio igualitario sin embargo
también hay otros candidatos en una
segunda fila que podrían colarse en una
segunda ronda que se llevaría a cabo el
3 de abril próximo